can you give an example of what needs to
happen in the first three pages of a
screenplay I love that because
uh you know I teach a class on getting
your script contest ready and this in
this class we focus on the first three
pages and how important they are it used
to be that you needed something amazing
to happen in the first 15 pages of your
script but audience has attention today
with social media and everything online
you know I'm like much prefer you need
to grab their attention right away
hopefully in page one not even page
three you know for me it's that page one
needs to be amazing and I always say
that that page needs to show either your
protagonist or your antagonist in action
and by that obviously I don't mean giant
explosion you know you could be writing
a dramatic piece that doesn't have that
it's more about showing who they are by
what they're doing not just describing
it I don't like slow openings where
they're just waking up going through
their morning routine you know and in
page three then they leave the house and
something happens give me me something
right away show me who they are but what
they're doing don't just describe it yes
you can get away you know with giving us
a description when you first introduce
your character you know and you're
writing like their name their age and a
little something about them but if
you're also showing us who they are
maybe they're in the meds of an
interesting conversation debating
something exciting you know you're
showing us oh these are the type of
characters that have a point of view
they have an opinion so that could also
be showing them in action but I think
that that needs to happen in those first
three pages you need to show something
unique like for example uh an exercise
that I love to do with my students is
rewriting the opening of friends if you
could do that how would you do it
because if you actually read the pilot
which is great and I love the show uh
it's an older show you know now we
expect things to happen quicker so I
always tell my students okay so how
would you get get this amazing teaser
and make it quicker well Rachel should
show up much quicker in the actual pilot
it takes like 10 pages for Rachel to
walk through those doors in her wedding
dress you know and oh everything clicks
for everyone because you know Ross is
into her and then the Dynamics start
because it starts pretty slow it's good
it's funny but it's just the other
characters you know they're just talking
they're sharing anecdotes about dating
in your 20s in New York City which is
fun but that could be later in the pilot
like you can show a little bit of their
Dynamics you know one page of this like
fan banter but then introduce Rachel
which is the element of surprise that's
what we want to see we want to see
something shaking the dynamic shaking
The Ordinary World of the characters and
also in action because as soon as she
walks in then we understand oh my God
Ross is in love with her and he's like
this jittery guy that just gets up
because she's there he opens the
umbrella and like all of the physical
comedy so if you can get something like
that in the first three ages of your
script and not by page 10 or 15 like it
used to be then that's when you're
grabbing your audience's attention
well if we took let's say Breaking Bad
or the Queen's Gambit a lot of things
happened in the beginning of those shows
but forgive me going back to uh When
Harry Met Sally how would we see
conflicts within the first three pages
it's been a little bit but it's a fairly
tame movie What conflict exists what
what antagonists exist well they are
I always say that the movie's Harry's
movie and Sally is
Harry's antagonist because he's really
the one with the Ark in the movie and if
you think even the title it's When Harry
Met Sally right like what happens to him
this pessimistic person that has to read
the last page of their of a book before
even starting the book in case he dies
or if something happens you know uh he
meets his exact opposite the super
chipper happy personality that just
clashes with him right she thinks that
you can be friends with men he doesn't
think that you can do that you know
things like that so I think that in that
case
that Dynamic is the way I would
introduce it right away and it kind of
is there in the script it just takes a
little bit because like Harry's kind of
saying goodbye to the girl who's his
girlfriend at the time but I would get
to that quicker I would just have the
goodbye happen immediately in the first
you know quarter of the first page and
then just get them in the car Harry and
Sally and her being like Oh you said
goodbye and then just get to that banter
because that's how I would introduce
those characters in action which is the
way I think that you should introduce
your protagonist you know they should be
sharing those points of view right away
so
she could be you know being all the
chipper and he could just bring out his
ideas on like books and stuff like that
and that's how I would introduce it in
the first three pages
also because
you know when you're talking to writers
about those three page count or whatever
it's because you want to grab readers
attentions and one of the best ways you
know to get your career started is to
send your scripts you know to
competitions and things like that and in
competitions
imagine that thousands and thousands of
scripts that they get right it's
overwhelming to even think about and in
a lot of competitions the first round
they kind of like read the first Pages
if they're not really hooked they might
pass on it the big competitions are
mandated to read the whole thing right
away but there's still many to go
through that you're reading like that
and you're like okay I'm not engaged by
Page Three I'm not really advancing you
to the next stage so you want you know
to really grab that reader's attention
and be like okay there's something
interesting here
the voice of the writer you know that
has to come out in those first three
pages the protagonist or the antagonist
has to be introduced in an interesting
way and that's really how you hook your
reader why do you say the first three
pages have to be the best three pages of
the script
because you always get a first
impression it's like you know the moment
you see someone you already get an idea
of who they are just by looking at them
or something like that when you get a
script and you get that first page it's
like that first dance that you're having
with a script you know if the first page
is not formatted correctly for example
it's like looking at someone who's
dressed terribly and you're like you're
getting that impression you know from
them so everything needs to look good on
the page you need to know screenwriting
formatting and that but then obviously
it's not just that it's way more than
that you have to be introducing a
character in an exciting way you have to
be revealing the world the tone the
genre there's a lot of elements that
need to be included in those three pages
and that tells your reader that you know
your story you know your genre you know
what you're saying you know who your
characters are and there's sort of a
promise of that story you're about to
tell so for example in that first page I
should immediately know if you're
telling a comedy a drama a thriller or
what it is or if it's a mashup you know
a horror comedy there should be a little
bit of both in that first page
so I immediately know you know what to
expect when I'm reading uh the world
should be evident right is this a world
where magical occurrences happen I hate
reading a script where the magic doesn't
happen until page 20 something and
there's no little setup of the beginning
of anything and then whoa I'm like
taking out of the world of the story
because like I'm like okay you set up a
certain world with certain rules you
can't just magically change everything
without like little setups I'm not
saying a magical occurrence has to
happen on page one but you have to set
it up as a world where magical
occurrences could potentially happen
sometimes you plan something like they
use crystals you know they're playing
with a Ouija board or something just to
tell you there's something like that
that is okay in this world
and then obviously an interesting
protagonist or antagonist something
interesting in action maybe a Twist by
Page Three and then also most
importantly your voice and your point of
view have to be there as a writer I feel
like producers and contests and anyone
out there who wants to read scripts is
trying to discover new voices that's
really what they're trying to do
stories are so many out there and so
many writers so what makes you the best
person to tell a certain story because a
lot of people are trying to tell the
same story as you right that's why you
can't copyright an idea you can
copyright a script but not just your
idea it's all about your voice your
point of view I love for example Juno
that's one of my favorite examples
because Diablo Cody was her very first
script you know she won the Academy
Award for this and the story is so
simple if you think about it it's a
teenage girl that gets pregnant that has
been told I don't know how many times
but probably hundreds of times it's a
simple story she gets pregnant what
happens she eventually gives the baby
out for adoption you know
but what made Juno unique is that a
voice
it was so impressive of Diablo Cody
capture a voice of a generation in this
teenagers that talked with a level of
banter that had never been seen before
you know they were so Snappy so original
they just kept you at the edge of your
seat because they were witty they were
so interesting to listen to they had
quick comebacks that just flew off the
page you know so that makes that script
unique even though it's the stories
being told so many times and even in
that first page you see that you know uh
Juno is taking a pregnancy test at this
convenience these store you know and and
she's just having this banter with the
clerk there about like an Etch A Sketch
and things like that you know like
they're trying to read the pregnancy
test and he's like it's not like an Etch
A Sketch you can just like change the
answer
things like that just show the point of
view that a voice so unique the way
you're describing things and that's
you know what you're trying to discover
in those three first few pages of a
script especially in a contest you know
to get so many submissions producers
agents the same
get them that first impression that is
unique and they want to keep reading you
know you get so many scripts when I was
working you know at a desk at the studio
a million years ago I would just have
piled some piles of scripts you know and
I would just like glance at them at
first and be like oh this first page
looks interesting okay I will read this
one first you know so give them a reason
to read your script right away and want
to keep turning pages
which is more common a great first three
pages of a script or three bad pages of
a script
s to say that it's more common like
three bad pages
uh I always say that out of a hundred
scripts I would maybe recommend three
uh that's not to say that there's
nothing in the other scripts that's not
salvageable obviously I would say
there's a lot to work with most of the
times but sadly
bad pages are more common than the first
three being great and it's sad because a
lot of the times the greatest comes
after they're just not hooking me right
away so a lot of the times as I'm
reading the script and I'm giving notes
to the writer I'm suggesting you know
why don't you move this up to the
beginning you know the way for example
Breaking Bad did it and that's one of my
favorite examples uh when I'm talking
about how to do a great pilot
Breaking Bad is a very unique case
because it's technically a premise pilot
which I always say it's a No-No a
premise pilot is when basically you're
telling all of like the backstory or
setup and only at the end the story
actually begins and that's boring
because if we're writing a pilot what we
want is the template for a real episode
right because we're only reading the
pilot we're not reading any other
episodes uh unless obviously eventually
you get to write them so what you want
where you're reading a pilot is to see
exactly what the style and story will be
week after week right if you're writing
a premise pilot on the story only starts
at the end then you are not really
giving me a template for what to expect
with Breaking Bad the way they did that
is so unique because they cheated the
system basically and gave us a Flash
Forward at the very beginning the pilot
starts with Walter in the future you
know in like the Winnebago and his
undies you know running from everything
that's happening cooking meth and
everything he's recording himself for
his wife and saying this is not an
admission of guilds but I love you blah
blah we hear the siren of the cops and
everything
uh so we're like oh my God what did this
guy do you know then he had two and we
go to the past which is really the start
of the episode and this backstory that
set up where he's you know a boring
depressed chemistry teacher with a
teenage son a baby on the way midlife
crisis all of that you know then he gets
diagnosed with cancer and all of that
have the pilot not started with that
killer Flash Forward it would have been
really slow paced and we maybe would not
have been as hooked so that's a great
example in those first three pages
really hook the reader because they show
me the promise of the show this Flash
Forward tells me oh okay this show will
get really interesting because this
person is going to be running from the
police or whatever you know cooking meth
and then the contrast to this chemistry
teacher in the midlife crisis and the
rest of the episode kind of follows that
pattern you know more like his
day-to-day life and showing us his
crisis and all of that his diagnosis and
everything but we already know what to
expect so we're trying to find little
tidbits there of like oh my god when is
he literally Breaking Bad which is the
title of the show when the whole Arc of
the show right the five seasons are
about Walter Breaking Bad
so we're trying to find little plans in
the episode of oh my god when is he
going to go somewhere that it's going to
lead to that opening but those three
pages are really what sold the show in
my opinion because oh that's the promise
of what I want to watch
what if I bump it up what if I say I'm
gonna give you all the good stuff and
the first one and a half and Maya is
that premature am I rushing it oh no I
don't think so I mean honestly if you
can give me a shocker by the end of page
one that hooks me even more and I want
to read more obviously try to continue
delivering and not just give me a Twist
then and then just a super passive
script as it goes along try and give us
some twists and Revelations but the
sooner you can hook your audience I
think is best
and so for your class that you do
getting your screenplay uh contest ready
it's at UCLA extension at grade school
by the way and um so you have people do
sort of mock readings and you because I
saw in the description that everyone's
going to bring one completed screenplay
so yeah I mean we do different sort of
exercises you know uh the same as we do
sort of in my script doctoring class
obviously focus in different areas you
know one would be more focusing on your
script and getting it contest ready and
the script doctoring is how you would
doctor other people's scripts you know
but I like to get those pages you know
and sort of like Implement all of these
things and try to see how would you how
would you hook your audience sooner What
would
how would you take what's here and work
around to really reflect all of the
things that we're learning you know all
of the things that we've mentioned like
they're presenting your character in
action or delivering a Twist or showing
your voice the world the tone the genre
all of that in those first one to three
pages of your script
and is that really what you're you're
working on the entire no it's not the
entire course obviously like we we work
on that a little bit and then on other
areas on how to really improve your
scripts and how to you know appeal to
contest readers or things like that
because obviously it's not just about
those three pages if you're sending your
script and you hope to win a contest
it's about the entire finished work
right so we would talk about the
structure and we would talk about how
the protagonist Arc has to be connected
to all of the turning points and how you
have to plant all of the right seeds in
act one that need to be paid off by act
three or for example how you have to
have a protagonist that has a clear core
wound or flaw that is going to affect
the way they go about their Journey
right they they have to change they have
to Arc and there has to be something set
up and then we need to see tidbits of
this growth right maybe at the midpoint
we have a step back and then things get
worse before they get better and
tracking all of those different elements
to deliver a full thing because it's
again obviously the first three pages
need to be amazing but that's not your
entire script you need to deliver a
complete final product right so it all
needs to track whatever you set up there
needs to be paid off and I think that
you need to give your audience credit
you know you they love kind of putting
the pieces together of all of this
planting that you're doing in the script
so if you can plan something in those
first three pages and then kind of
deliver later and have a great payoff
then you're connecting with your reader
you're connecting with your audience
you're giving them the credit that
they're putting the pieces together
creating the story that they're getting
involved in because you're giving them
little things to get involved with